yeah
[Applause]
Michael
three point Houston leave
Rubio four seconds three seconds step
back by Hardin's pennies pal
the Jazz been pushing harden to his
right all game longing to see James
stepping back problem with forcing James
to his right is when he comes back to
his left hand to shoot he draws fouls
very easily that yeah
[Applause]
MVP is the champ go too hard and be
paired with Kevin and Calvin we recap
glides of players to watch and of course
we do talk about James Harden being
named Western Conference Player of the
Week and we hear from head coach Mike
D'Antoni and rockets players coming up
after the game so thank you miss shell
and here we go now 13 on the Jersey
James Harden
54 points accounted so far in this game
by Harden and the MVP champ
[Applause]
you know when you're talking about him
going back to his right to shoot it like
that people forget to his 6:5 and he
holds that ball up over his head
so that's tough inning on a defense's go
the ball midway through the poor curry
[Applause]
this I'd like to see this again I'll
take one thing you can remove move your
feet when the ball is out of your hands
and you're dribbling in the balls out of
your hands you can take all all the
steps you want now let's see if we did
comes around on the dribble
well it's James Harden that is the heart
I met James ass every James Harden three
right there every backups cut it extra
money he just a step back he travels
every single time he does it just like
that in infants and that is a travel so
good call by car Lane let's see that
called in the Rockets game four
[Music]
which is what we weren't it is anymore
to the best going it